as dozens of police officers stood
outside a fourth grade classroom at Rob
Elementary on the other side of the
unlocked door a gunman completed the
massacre of 19 children and two teachers
the US attorney general says the
police's hesitation of more than an hour
cost innocent lives as a consequence of
failed leadership training and policy
injured and scared students and teachers
remain trapped with a subject in the
classrooms waiting to be rescued
following a 20mon investigation the US
Department of Justice's nearly 600 page
report details the police's mistakes
they include treating the G as a
barricaded subject rather than an active
shooter and though more than 300
officers responded no one took clear
charge okay clear police finally entered
the classroom 77 minutes into the
shooting killing the 18-year-old gunman
for these officers who sit there and
just not do anything you know and U
still be out here you know on the
streets like nothing happened you
know and my daughter's gone about a
handful of police officers lost their
jobs in the aftermath grieving parents
say some should be prosecuted for
neglect I hope that the failures end
today and the local
officials do what wasn't done that day
do right by the victims and survivors of
Rob Elementary terminations criminal
prosecutions the federal report does not
recommend criminal charges and President
Joe Biden appeared to agree we're going
to do what we can't implement the
recommendations of the justice
department but I don't know that there's
any criminal liability the report
recommends more than 270 lessons learned
from Uvalde including that officers
should immediately neutralize the
shooter in an active shooter scene the
victim's families also fault lawmakers
for the lack gun laws that allowed their
children's killer to purchase his weapon
Heidi Joe Castro alzer
Washington well that's it
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz